(audience cheering and applauding)
All right, you know what that means,
it is time for Drew's News, the magical good news snowflake
that you catch on your tongue.
(everyone laughing)
And with me at the desk is my little snow angel,
Rossy Ross Matthews.
That's right, hi everybody.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Oh my God.
Aren't those the best?
The best.
They really are.
All right, well, let's get into some even better news.
First up we've got the perfect couch wear collection
for your next big streaming binge.
Apartment therapy reports that Netflix has partnered
with Unhide to create a cozy line of throw blankets, robes,
and ponchos.
They're a hundred percent cruelty-free
and made from leftover fabrics.
Ooh, up cycle.
And you can slide from Netflix and chill right into Netflix
and fall asleep on the couch.
Oh wow.
Well, hi chill.
(audience applauds)
Chill.
Do you, clap of hands,
how many people know what chill means?
Yeah, you were all.
(applauding)
Yes, yeah.
I didn't know.
You didn't know?
No, because does anyone clap of hands, remember chill
in the eighties and nineties was like relax.
Yeah, like I like, I want to Netflix and chill, but no,
I want to chill the nineties style,
which is just like to relax.
And it was like be mellow, man.
Chill.
Well, okay.
So at the beginning of a relationship,
you Netflix and chill, and then, then you just chill,
you know.
You Netflix and couch potato.
Exactly.
Just, you just binge, but just on 90 Day Fiance.
That's what you do.
(Drew and audience laugh)
But I think people will, you know,
definitely be excited for these blankies.
Oh, they gonna chill all right.
(Drew squeals)
We see you.
You know, we love a really good holiday dinner debate,
and we've got a hot one fresh out of the oven
and it comes from jolly old England.
Except in this case, hold the jolly.
The Mirror reports a woman says her brother-in-law
and sister-in-law are hosting Christmas dinner
and they're charging a cover to come.
(audience groans)
Yes, even for family.
What?
She says, this woman says that she personally
has hosted Christmas dinner in the past.
She would never charge a cover.
She offered, she said, I'll bring a meal,
but they said they wanted cold, hard cash.
What?
Yes, and this woman's husband sides with the relatives.
Yes.
Wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute.
I'm a little confused.
Yeah.
They want to charge someone for coming over
for a holiday dinner.
That's exactly what they want to do.
What, can't we just kick it old school
and do a potluck?
Girl, why you?
'Cause what are you going to have a bouncer
next to the jello mold to make sure that I didn't.
I mean, does anyone think this is a good idea?
No.
I would kind of like, this gets me all,
this really ruffles my feathers Rossy.
I don't like it.
I (groans).
I know.
What would you say?
I would just be like, well, I'll be at home.
I'll zoom in.
Can, do ya charge for that?
I think it would bring out my rebellious side.
Totally.
I think I'd be like, really?
You want to charge me?
And then I would say a bunch of things
I can't say right now.
(everyone laughing)
But you know what I'm thinking.
See ya next year.
Oh we know what you're thinking.
We know what you're thinking.
You know what I'd do.
I host my own and say, everyone come to mine, it's free.
Yeah, exactly.
Come on.
I got you.
Exactly, exactly.
Well next, we have a man who was no match
for his local buffet's all you can eat offer.
Rossy, you love a buffet.
I love a buffet and I feel very strongly about this story.
Okay, so Food and Wine reports,
a live streamer in China known as Mr. Kang
is no longer welcome at Handadi Seafood and Barbecue Buffet
because he eats too much.
The restaurant owner says he loses money every time Mr. Kang
walks in the door.
I wonder if Mr. Kang went to one of these family's parties
and now that's why they're charging.
Okay, so how much food are we talking here?
One time he ate eight pounds of prawn,
which is approximately 300 prawns
by our rough prawn math.
Ya know, prawn math.
It's sweeping the nation.
I mean, all you can eat is a dare.
What do you think, Rossy?
Listen to me, sir, I will represent you in court pro bono.
Okay?
All you can eat means all you can eat, okay?
I will approach the bench for you.
Till my dying day, I will fight for this.
Buffets mean buffet for a reason.
You understand?
(audience cheers and applauds)
So, don't come at me.
Don't tell me.
You know this gets me heated.
I never get this upset about this,
but you tell me all I can eat, challenge accepted.
Well, it isn't all you can eat until I say so.
Yeah, that sign is too long.
It's not as catchy.
(audience applauds)
It means all you can eat
I'm doing it.
All right, next, we got a fuzzy wuzzy fashion trend
this season.
InStyle reports, the faux bucket hat, AKA, the Muppet hat.
Do you know this?
Well, it's showing up on heads everywhere.
No.
Checkout Bella Hadid, muppeting around New York City.
What do you think, Drew?
Well, I said no, because I just didn't like the trend
in the first place, but now seeing it on these girls,
I really like it.
So I guess, you know, a picture can change your mind.
Can you?
See I don't look good.
(audience cheering)
I guess we're not Bella Hadid, Ross.
Why do I look like a gay mushroom?
(everyone laughing)
Why do I look like,
an eighties like rejected, I don't know.
Who am I trying to think of?
The thing is you kind of look cute in yours.
I look like I'm on Mario Brothers.
I feel like I'm like a rejected kid
in the Fat Albert gang.
Like this just doesn't work.
All right.
No, oh.
Can I see yours 'cause it matches my outfit.
Maybe that's the problem.
Okay, well, here's the thing.
I mean, does anyone like these hats?
(audience cheers)
No, no, no.
It wasn't the color, it wasn't the color.
By the way, you just turned into
like a Blues Clues character.
Oh my God.
Come on kids.
(everyone laughing)
(upbeat music)